but let's make an important Point you're
talking about a quality equaling respect
the way you get respect as a woman is by
being feminine there's nothing we can be
equal and very very different I'm not
saying that when there's not equality
but you've confused equality with the
same you can be equal with completely
different things you can have a bishop
and a knight on a chessboard they're
equal in terms of points but they do
different things right a woman can have
equal respect to a man if she is very
good at being a woman and a man gets
respect for being very good at being a
man when a woman decides she wants to
act like a man or a man wants to act
like a woman that's where all gets
[__] up we try and pretend it's all
the same it's not the same men and women
are good at different things we have
different strengths different weaknesses
there's nothing wrong with accepting
that there's nothing wrong with saying
I'm a woman I'm good at X he's a man
who's good at why then we work together
as a team we have a beautiful family
we're happy forever it's only confused
where you have women who sit and go no
because in the name of equality we can
fight and work there's no [__] women
on the front line in Ukraine that is
silent [__] they put some chick
there dancing around doing Pokemon
dancers to try and convince men to get
[__] die in a ditch it's garbage if
you go to the front line of Ukraine
right now you do not see women in their
makeup and their manicures you see
[__] men in in the freezing cold
dying you know where the women are Dubai
chilling that's where the women are so
to sit and pretend that women are just
as capable physically as men as a
[__] lies delusion descending your
strongest man is delusion you are good
at other things you're better than men
at a lot of things but it's not the
physical world and the unfortunate
reality about life this is what we're
saying when I was saying earlier that
feminism goes out the window when things
get hard the harder the world gets it
the closer it gets to the Baseline of
humanity the unfortunate Baseline of
humanity is violence that's what happens
when if of all the electricity you were
to go out and all the police sort of
quit this would become a violent place
very quickly and there would be [__]
zero feminists left zero you would all
need men that's the bottom line of
reality that's the bottom line so you
have to understand as a woman and say
okay but I need a man who's good at
being a man but no one's saying that we
don't need men in society of course we
do we're talking about relationships
yeah you're strong but the thing is I
can live my life as a woman and not need
a man what's a woman
[Laughter]
yes we need men in society but in
relationships the only reason I actually
need you is because I want you I don't
actually need you do you know what I
need you I need you to procreate yes I
agree but the things I don't need you in
my day-to-day life but wait wait wait
what if someone breaks into your house
I'll just call the police okay what if
they don't come what if the average in
the US it takes like 50. in the US it
takes like 15. that is for them to get
that's not realistic okay no no no okay
okay these two guys in your in your
house what are you doing that's not
realistic I've not had any man break
into my house on a day-to-day it doesn't
happen the point is
that I know what you're saying but the
point is this the point is
when we're talking about feminism as a
whole feminism as a whole demonizes men
and you just said you just sat and said
besides procreation I don't need a man
in my life I can go to a male mechanic
or call a male police officer they're
men so it's it it's Society I agree I
agree of course we need you of course so
you're talking about being with a man
because you want to so my question to
you is why would you want to be with
them why would a man want to be with you
because they're sexy like obviously
in a good relationship right one that
works there's Blue Jobs and there's pink
jobs right and that's the problem that
women have got oh gee they don't want to
be doing those paint jobs
we're talking about relationships why do
you need a man in a relationship because
you want a partner which companionship
friendship romantic love things that you
can't get by yourself like you want to
go on dates with him it's not about I
need someone to fix my car like go to a
mechanic You're Not Safe call the police
what about a father to your kids you
don't think you're excited you can be
around I definitely want but these are
the stuff this is the reasons
I agree wait wait wait it's not it's not
that you want it you need it I agree and
these are the stuff that I need in a man
but it's like at the end of the day it's
not like I completely need you all the
whole but the whole point is if the
lights went out tomorrow you would need
a man
like women useless
I'm saying if if the lights went out
tomorrow you would need someone to
protect you
say something
this is why you can't blame all men for
your poor choices
you can't say I'm talking to both of you
because you're not saying yeah my man
can't do this my man can't do that what
and you want to settle down why would
you go and choose a man
that can't do these things that you
wanted them to do because my man could
do all the blues I need a man because
most men grow up with a place
speak for yourself speak for yourself
my boyfriend you know what I need a
father to my children I don't need you
know something right she needs a police
officer she needs a farmer for her
children right so she's gonna go out
there right and you're going to buy your
child an electric car you're gonna go
and buy your child a bicycle who the
hell is going to play the bicycle and
fix the electric car who doesn't do it
you've got YouTube I know how to do
these things
yourself go and get some sperm done or
something because you obviously don't
need a man that's the future the future
for who no of course
let me finish talking right now you can
you got a man right and you've been busy
all day right and you're in your bed at
one o'clock in the morning and your man
comes in with all of his friends
and said oh babies that all the friends
are here they're hungry what you're
gonna do yeah I'll cook for my man I I'm
I'm a traditional woman and I ask that
yeah
that when people start cooking they
think that that cooking is traditional
it's everything it's not just about
cooking everything
I have a question are you virgin you're
traditional you're a virgin are you a
virgin
in that aspect I'm not gonna comment on
me being a virgin or not but what I'm
gonna say is every every human being
should be able to cook
tradition and modernization that
survives you know I need to cook to
survive can I can I ask me to take
something right I'm gonna ask you
something sure right because I I can't I
don't like [__] right and like
there's not some people that I can't
wait so I'm gonna talk to him because so
far he's talking sense thank you very
much thank you it's giving pick me right
who said pick me
they want me
32 years I don't need to clap for myself
because I'm happy I'm not here and what
I was gonna ask him right is how would
you think a woman would you think that
woman would you think that woman who's
calm down I'm I'm loud I'm not sure you
don't want to hear me shout anyway Mr
take like I was saying before we got
rudely interrupted right now if you is
this your idea of a woman that you think
deserves a man
I'm here
single but I'm looking I mean I like
taking you know if you want to hook me
up let me know or not I just want
anybody but choose how does that make
you feel what is that kind of woman that
you think deserves a man well he's a top
G you can't be asking him this question
yeah
for yourself
we have options
we have options yeah you're out here
looking for a man you're out here saying
that you're looking yeah well that's
what I was looking for men oh my gosh
she was at the advertising when we done
the introductions that's what you're
saying
I didn't say I was going out looking for
a minute
listen to this insult right listen to
the outside
would you call it in Sign Language what
I'm learning sign language right listen
to what she just said to me unlike you I
have options [__] 32 years you think
I want options
though because
I'm sure you didn't mean pick me you
meant clout Chaser is that what it is
when you're the one advertising at the
beginning of the show I said I'm doing
interviews I wasn't advertising nothing
is that what an interview me okay she's
being spicy guys stop it Auntie had a
question for Andrew oh yeah what was
your question oh she asked already he
didn't answer because everybody's too
busy
jumping in already up but he's not too
busy jumping in and being women
shut up and let him answer in it I'll
I'll answer yeah so so to go back to one
of my earlier points firstly to make it
clear in the disagreement I agree with
of course I think everyone knows who I
agree with but um I do because you know
what it is though you know what's
actually funny
the things that she's saying our common
knowledge 20 30 years ago this is how
the world functioned this is how the
whole world functioned the things I say
that somehow people believe are
controversial are exactly the way the
world functioned in like the 90s the AES
the 70s all of the entire period of
human history men had a role of
masculinity women had a role of
femininity we worked as a team now the
world's come along and they've destroyed
and broken everything and there's this
new Progressive think and this new
generation of women who seem to believe
that if we completely [__] it all up
it's going to end up better and my
argument to that is listen we went from
walking around in fields and small
nomadic groups to building cities to
building the pyramids to going to the
Moon we managed to go from a few
thousand to billions of people populate
the entire planet build canals build
skyscrapers cities all of this was done
based on the back of man being a man
woman being a woman working together as
a family and I was destroyed now they're
gonna come along and [__] it up if it's
not broke it's destroyed it's been
destroyed the man has destroyed Earth
what are you talking about it's been bad
decisions from powerful men now go men
to go to Wars and from women to lose
husbands men built men make decisions
for war men kill men please listen to me
men built the Earth I'm not saying men
are perfect but the entire world that
you're existing under was built by man
yes so so and the point I'm making is
now we're entering a world of new think
and that the problem with new think is
it's not tested I don't give a [__] what
anyone's opinion is what I can state is
a matter of fact is we had 5 000 years
of history that tells us how the world
works with X and Y together we're now
entering a new paradigm There's No 5 000
years of History so whatever you believe
about how it's going to work or it's
gonna be better or worse whatever that's
just you guessing everyone is guessing
right so renting a brand new paradigm
and everything's completely [__] up
the point we were making earlier which
is a fantastic one about if I pick a
woman who's advertising Etc et cetera
men always please keep this in mind if
you're especially if you're a female
people always say you know the number of
emails I get from girls who say you
don't give enough girl games I'll give
you a girl game right now your man wants
status that's what he wants you need to
find a way to make him look good to the
world and to his friends so how do you
do that I'll tell you one of the ways a
man can get status is to get the girl
that no one can get that's a very simple
way right so I said not ready to mingle
I did right okay no no but this is the
truth right if you if I date a girl
and she's perfect in every way head to
toe and then I'd say I've met this girl
yes she's this she's this oh yeah I took
her for a date even if you didn't [__]
her if you [__] her no no just went for
a date so you went the attraction goes
from this to zero done and it may not
for some men because some men haven't
got choices but men like me who
genuinely have unlimited options we want
complete exclusivity that's what we're
looking for because that gives status
that's what you're looking for so you
have to be very careful as a female with
all of your actions all of your
interactions with your boyfriend or when
you're looking for a boyfriend Etc and
say am I gonna make my man look better
by doing X or look worse simple things
I've had endless arguments about girls
nights out right oh you're insecure it's
not about insecure I don't give a [__]
if no man talks to you all night long I
don't care if you're going out and
you're going to an all-girl Club I don't
care I know that when my boys say oh all
the girls are going out and I say not my
girl she stays home I look good that's
it she stays home she doesn't go she
doesn't want she doesn't want to go out
without me that status it's not about
the night out it's about the status of
being the man in the house that's what a
man wants he wants respect he wants to
be the man of the house I say she stays
home she stays home Big G boom boom
that's what we want can I ask you
something what about what does the the
woman want in your eyes what are you
thinking what's the game you get for the
boys I'm gonna tell you but before that
I need another Clementine and I need to
give half to our friend here because she
just rolls her eyes at me and I'm
perspicacious I know it's everything she
doesn't realize that I'm a ninja I
detect these things even when I'm
looking directly ahead I can detect it
I'm gonna give her some of my Clementine
and she's gonna feel better so I'm gonna
get a clementine would you like some
Clementine right now I'm sure I just I
think for me it's like I asked you a
question yeah I would love some you want
some Clementine yeah we're gonna hook it
up okay Clementine's coming all right go
on continue okay no I mean I just feel
like this is definitely a different
conversation for me because I I'm very
open-minded I love hearing different
perspective and I do feel like
um this is a newer idea like like you
said it was in the last 30 40 years this
is a New Concept we don't know how it's
going to end I just know from from like
my experience other women that I've met
as well it's like the reason for even
like relationships why they're not
lasting is because people don't want to
put up with the disrespect and like even
when you were talking about like oh it's
okay for me to cheat but not for you my
thing is is like why not have
transparency and have it be polygamous
polyamorous whatever works for you
that's like to me where it loses me with
the traditional stuff it's like why
can't we have transparency if I sign up
for that cool so how does it no okay no
no man no man in a millionaire let's all
be realistic right no man and
millionaire is going to meet a girl who
likes and go I want to be polyamorous
like come on that's gay let's cut this
[__] so let's let's be realistic how
does a man show love to a woman
exclusivity wrong time resources and
something else time resources so yeah
that's a good that's a good way to start
so sexual exclusivity is how female
shows primarily primarily that she's
interested in a man he's the only man
who has sexual access to me because I
can get pregnant and I this man is the
only man who can do it that's how it's
done a man yes I'm not saying all men
can cheat I'm not saying all men should
cheat I'm not saying that I'm saying
that if I truly love a woman she won't
sit there and go he shows me his love
because he doesn't [__] anyone else
she'll sit there and go he shows me his
love because my bills are paid I'm in a
Bentley I drive like private I go to
Dubai anytime I want I have a Chanel bag
and I'm not talking about just money I'm
talking about resource and a lifestyle
as a whole this is not just me this is
the world and most of the world today if
you go to Moscow and you find a big g a
rich guy right he has his wife she's
pushing a Bentley she's the kid she's
living in a mansion whatever when he
goes to the club with his boys you think
he ain't with 19 year old strippers of
course he [__] is she's just like
whatever don't care I'm the one who has
the money don't give a [__] so you have
to sit there and to a point you have to
sit and analyze the the difference when
you're saying disrespect if you're gonna
if you're gonna go through life as a
woman and say I only care about the
sexual exclusivity of my man then what
you're going to end up doing is having a
bunch of failed relationships and
[__] loads of dudes there has to get
a point where you go you know what this
guy takes so many boxes once a year
twice a year he's out with his boys does
some dumb [__] I'm just gonna pretend I
didn't notice because my bills are paid
I'm looked after I can tell he cares
about me if I have a problem he's gonna
fix it he's kicked something that's the
smart female move as opposed to go I
don't care how good he is to me he
[__] that [__] once so I'm gonna
leave and I'm gonna get another man who
I don't love who'll [__] another [__]
anyway and then I'll get another man who
and the cycle of dumb [__]
I have a question is there ever cheating
that's too far like so if a guy cheats
on a girl is there ever a point where
she yeah there's a lot of cheating
there's completely a lot of cheats like
if he if he knocks up another girl all
right all right so first things first
I'm a man of my word I don't even think
I'm a liar
so here's your Clementine
thank you and he peeled it I'm a
gentleman right so obviously I'm not
saying blatantly disrespect your woman
right she's your woman and she's your
queen she's the most important thing in
the world to you she needs to be
retreated in a way that she feels that
right but it's unfortunate because I
keep tying back to this Baseline point
but the reason I keep going back to this
Baseline point is to try and explain to
everybody at home how simple world the
world can be if you go back to the
baselines of it why do men cheat most
women don't know you'll see them all the
time why do men cheat all because manage
is stupid and why do men [__] girls
uglier than their main chick why do men
do all this stuff you know why I'll tell
you why let's go back to the first thing
I've been saying this whole time status
yeah that's my chick she's home took
this one home yeah I got that one she's
chasing me status but it's but it's
stupid to females I get it but that's
the male world because sexual access is
an easy indicator of status so that's
one of the reasons they do it right so
you have to go back into the Baseline of
white men even cheat in the first place
I'm telling you if you're a woman the
smartest thing you can do is look after
your man make him not want to cheat be
perfect but there's going to be a time
across a 20-year marriage you might just
need to be a little bit blind a little
bit
tiny [__] don't look at his phone
you'll be cool just make sure the bills
are paid he does his jobs the man well
if you can pay your own business but
this is it we'll talk about that in a
second but I'm not saying allow this for
some [__] Joe schmoe I'm not saying
let some [__] loser pick you up lock
you down I'm not saying that I'm saying
if he's a gene he's doing enough of his
other jobs as for you saying what if you
can pay your own bills then then what's
the reality you face just like I
described earlier I'm gonna decide that
the thing that I prioritize above
everything above his resource above the
amount he cares to me you'll see men
cheat on a woman and then cry his eyes
out trying to get that woman back he
still loves you it's not the same as if
you cheated he loves you with all his
heart he died for you he'd take a bullet
for you and he still [__] that [__]
doesn't matter it's a different game for
men right so you're sitting here going
well I don't I'm going to prioritize his
sexual exclusivity over all of his other
count all of his other attributes you're
just gonna end up having endless failed
relationships [__] too many dudes and
then what's gonna happen is your
psychology is gonna break because
females don't like to accept the fact
that if you sleep with enough men and
you get rid of the stigma around a new
dick your instant answer is new dick I
didn't text me today [__] it someone
else ah he was rude to me [__] I'll
cheat ah he was this I just got a new
boyfriend and then you end up just
jumping on [__] all day and you're
[__] done as many of you know I was
just banned on Tick Tock and we are
demonetized on a daily basis on this
platform if you want to help please
consider sending a super thanks below
every donation helps and it helps make
what we do possible